i i traveled with a a portable
humidifier for the plane
and as potential as that sounds it was a
lifesaver
like why you're imposing that on the
people around you no no no everyone
would like being humidified
no that's a really really small thing
and
i was often like a sweat oh man there's
no i'm i'm backpedaling because there's
no way this conversation's gonna go well
for me
[Laughter]
i would be in and i wouldn't be around
other people due to the nature of my
series right because you're in first
class with your [ __ ] humidifier troy
baker
yeah but here's the reason why i i
typically would hit the ground running
there's a lot
of very i loved the very gentle way i
wouldn't be around other people like
i wouldn't if i could help it
that's referred to us i would not fly
among the peasants
troy uh sees there's two there's two
seating areas of the plane there's the
troy section and then such a relatable
ship yeah
i've never flown first class so i don't
bring them
actually i'm with troy because when you
do it you start to
you start to resent not doing it and you
can
reach a point of no return and it's it's
good to just i did one time but it was
uh seattle to san francisco which is
like an hour flight that i
got upgraded for and i was like great
useful thank you appreciate it i i
remember we we were coming back from
hawaii
and we i didn't get my upgrade and i
remember pam looking missions i feel
like i'm in trouble
i have spoiled you look i'm only able to
do that because the auspices of other
people that have been
incredibly kind and very generous and
one of the reasons why
uh is because typically it was you hit
the ground especially at heathrow or
whatever and i am straight to work
so it became necessary for me to get
some good sleep
one of the things that i found is that
at altitude in that cabin
i would get really really dried out so
having this little personal humidifier
and literally you it's it's like it
looks like a plastic donut
and you screwed a water bottle into it
and then you just like dumped it over it
flips like this and it would just last
for six hours like a little
every like it was
as a journalist i've also done a lot of
fly places hit the ground running
definitely no first class forty thousand
dollar a year salary
uh in san francisco how long were those
flights
i mean one time i had to go to uh
gamescom it took me 32 hours and i had
to work two hours after landing
you know there's a direct flight from
australia
oh from australia no no it's no direct
flight they they aren't friendly to
world was spherical there would be
though wouldn't that you know that's the
thing that's what i'm saying is
is it the flat flat moon is what we're
into now apparently
the moon is flat i missed it i thought
the moon was a projection
oh is that true i i can't keep up i
don't get the news literally it's
something that's like
if you can't throw a stone in it and hit
it then it's not real or something
they're like they're convinced that you
should be able to hit the stone if you
throw
i'm not because gravity may be also just
a theory
[ __ ] i think yeah i mean technically
gravity doesn't
because that makes me sound
look better get it i get really bad
pimples whenever i'm on a long flight
i'll get off and just wait wait wait
wait
no don't do it we gotta i gotta i gotta
don't bring the private conversation
into this
off the record i'll start alana said
it's just a theory and i gotta i gotta
dig into that one a little bit
because it is a that is a
an area where uh colloquial use of the
word theory
and the actual scientific discipline
you the the those who practice the
discipline of science
uh use that word very differently
because it is in
in real science there is nothing above
theory everything is theory yeah
no no it's not that it's that the most
the hot like
the theory of gravity for example
is the most robust form our knowledge of
gravity takes because what it means
theory is basically a way of saying
we have a model that works and has
predictive
power of we can put values in and get
empirically verifiable values out
and but that's not the same thing as
saying a
law or a proof because those are
basically mathematical concepts that
don't
really exist in science because
we could discover something about
gravity tomorrow
that changes our conception of the way
it works
and just informs and refines the working
theory the working model of gravity so
when most people say theory what they
really mean is hypothesis
uh because that means you know
it's our i think it's our guest that we
want to test
yeah we have not done anything i was
like i wonder if this is true
and i haven't done any testing
whatsoever
because if it was a theory that means
that it would have somehow stood up
against
some testing well that is that it would
be
to be a theory it would be your you made
effort to prove your hypothesis which is
the inherent bias behind it
is that you have the hypothesis you
prove it as best you can
but am i not correcting saying that that
most things in science are a theory like
physics is
a theory there's only a few laws right
again laws are kind of a different term
and also
not nearly so consistently defined
because
laws of thermodynamics like those are
again it's it's again it's more
colloquial i am
all about this by the way i am awesome
that was called a law it was called a
law because the era in which it was
arrived upon
we wanted to like call everything a law
you know it was a very
it's the same reason that it took a long
time for scientists or i guess
paleontologists to understand that uh
dinosaurs were theoretically
better than currently existing animals
because the theory for a very long time
was that by definition for an animal to
become extinct it must be inferior to
later forms
so dinosaurs for the until very recently
um were always assumed to be these awful
slovenly
beasts because otherwise why did they
die out why would they be
why would there be things on the planet
that were bet that were worse than a
dinosaur
but then they found the movies that they
made and the books that they wrote
exactly
well scientists went to dressing park
you see so that was how they they were
like oh okay yeah that makes sense
but there was it's definitely like it's
rooted in kind of there's the victorian
view of science and the modern view of
science which are very different and
austin's talking about the modern
perspective the laws
and the kind of those kind of we are
going to empirically and
empirically hey um like apply
logic to the world and say we know what
is what is very much rooted in kind of a
victorian view of the world for sure
and i also think the um related to that
i should say slightly
peripheral to it um the whole
catchphrase from um the
notion of uh natural selection and
darwinian evolution of so-called
survival of the fittest
the word fittest is often misconstrued
there because it me it often is thought
to mean
strongest uh or is this yeah there you
go
no you should be pulling out oh this is
a really interesting book by the way
yeah ron brooke how science audio is
this is roman
science of romans
survival of the fittest understood
properly is that which
fits in its environment it's not the
strongest
it's the it's not the strongest it's not
the fastest you can be really slow and
stupid does the word
fittest have that alternate meaning it's
the most relevant
it's quite fitting or if in the uk
yeah it's it's it's a kind of archaic
use of the word but that term does not
mean
survival of the people especially in the
kind of
disgusting social darwinist conversation
where people
especially if you go back like even to
that victorian era
it was a justification for a lot of
horrible racism because it would
basically be like
well you know look the europeans showing
up with their muskets and those
those brutish savages in the untamed
lands like survival of the fittest right
like we're just proving we
we are worth the money
that makes right and and the whole point
is to say that that
that you that's a [ __ ] justification
because that's not even what survival
never mind that that's just
that's just horrible but but it's not
even a proper understanding of what
survival of the fetish even means
because
that which that which is best able to
endure the environmental
conditions in which it's survival of the
best suited to its environment yeah
that's yeah
that's all that that's less it would
that wouldn't fit on the front of the
book though
this is the worst thing i've ever said
and i feel very uncomfortable saying it
but
does that not sort of apply being that
one party has
you know super advanced munitions would
they not be more
fit under that
i think it's an interesting question on
if if
humanity has kind of graduated outside
the
the the realm of natural selection well
i feel like we have we are now evolving
in technology where effectively cyborgs
the fact that everyone holds a phone
all the time and always has it on them
we're not far away i don't feel like
there have been as many advancements in
physical evolution we are now having
more advancement in our tools
but when does adult when does adult
lactose processing come in i think that
was the last kind of biological
evolution that's been tracked huh
because basically because you shouldn't
be able to
uh digest after six or something yeah
right i mean so we develop that as a res
or we developed that
sorry apologies that we frame this in
the right scientific way we developed
that concurrently and therefore
those with this ability uh bred and
therefore survived
and evolved with that was the that was
humans
that comes in around farming because
that's when we start having cows to
drink milk from
but i asked them almost chasing cows in
the wild transplants
milk is milk milk as an adult becomes a
food that comes in
in the last chasing down cows to milk
them thousands of years ago no but it's
true we're literally somewhere
that's i think that's the last
biological evolution that has been kind
of
tracked as something becoming redundant
in theory is
sort of a but that would go back
millions of years
mike's talking about like in in recent
in on the order of thousands of years
our our our our intrinsic
relationship to lactose has changed in a
way that proliferates
yeah it's a gene switch so there was
there's a there's a
there's a this is and again like i'm the
layman so i'm definitely going to be
talking about saying something
my understanding is that ascension not
scientists definitely are scientists we
need a fake video please play watch
listen
science watch listen play watch citizens
to study um
but like no it was literally a switch
it's a there's uh there's uh you're
meant you're meant historically and most
animals on the planet
uh can process milk up until childhood
like until the point where they would
stop nursing and at that point
um you you in your in your physical
development and maturing
it gets switched off as a thing you can
do and that's you know
that is something that that's the last i
think that's the
or it's often used as an example of one
of the last biological evolutions
which comes in after farming a favorite
tree
you think of farms as modern humans and
they are the humans that
made farms are modern humans in most
extents but there's a biological
difference that
comes in and obviously because it's so
recent there is still variability in the
population which is why some people
can't process milk
it's mostly and i think they're wrong i
think it's still a lot it's i think it's
the right i don't know what the ratio is
but it's like you know but it does tie
to that history of
um of milk drinking and cultural and
therefore is very cultural in a lot of
ways as well which is interesting
but this is where the role of technology
really fundamentally alters how natural
selection would
would otherwise have worked because
there can be
like there could be a drug for example
that assists
the lactose intolerant and therefore
those who
can't whose genes never flipped will
continue to reproduce and spread their
lactose intolerant genes because society
has found and and to me the obvious
example of this is
if you go back you know not that long
ago
uh if you had really crap eyesight you
were not
likely to be having children uh or at
least
you or your children wouldn't survive
long enough and and there would be a
pretty
strong uh environmental selective
pressure
on on those with good eyesight but as
soon as
we developed glasses uh now it's like it
seems to me inevitable that over time
gradually all of humanity will start to
move in the direction of having crap
eyesight but you're right that's the
like the word that's important in all of
these conversations is likely
in the in so far as insofar as this is
i think often when we think about these
things we think about like the bird
whose beak is not like
big enough to get to the ants therefore
that dies out
this is this is it's a lot like wish
listing a game
on steam which you also always do
in the sense of large populations you
don't actually
need um drastic differences between
uh population groups and their behaviors
to go in a direction
so it doesn't matter that most people
wish list a game on steam and then never
buy it
some do and there's enough that do that
it can make a difference
and the same is true in in evolutionary
terms of like
it doesn't necessarily yes glasses
change the the the situation with
eyesight but
theoretically um that means that uh that
doesn't mean that all people have access
to glasses or and that those be
so there's a really there's an
interesting kind of trend but then the
other thing that's important with
evolution and this is why
um whenever people go towards kind of
the creepier more racist ends of these
conversations which we're obviously
nowhere near but
does come up with humans and evolution
all these kind of conversations
is there's a lot of stuff that there
isn't evidence that actually has any
relationship to evolution or to
um uh biological preferences there's you
can't you if you
you can't breed for right for
intelligence for example all this kind
of creepy kind of stuff that again came
in the victorian mindset
of um you know nasty stuff
is this is kind of either disproven or
has never been proven like and it's it's
unsurprising there's a lot there's a lot
of evidence that differences between
humanity tend to come down more to
culture
and opportunity than they come down to
biological differences in
most cases that seems to be kind of the
consensus of mine i know that
the modern science the general uh
i was going to say consensus but then
you said consensus and now it seems like
we're saying consensus too much and i
can't think of an adjective
or a synonym rather um the the reason
that that humans are the superior
species which is really only and that we
have
control of the planet effectively is
just because we were able to use tools
effectively
that's it that's all it actually comes
down to is is not it's not anything
genetic other than we were able to
use tools the one thing down the
monolith you can actually
you can actually push that farther the
other direction
we in that realm of the idea of being
fit for your environment
we live all kinds of places that we are
not actually biologically fit to survive
the very fact that we have humans in
space which would instantaneously kill
us without intervening technology but
most of this planet is this true for
as well like we can't without the
ability to make clothing and shelter
the it's no wonder why civilization
developed in the world where it did you
know the the sort of
you know areas of africa and the middle
east because it's by far the most
hospitable climate on planet earth
and and and as soon as you start going
too far north and south of that
we are much more frail than we like to
think of ourselves and without the
ability to develop
you know skinning animals for clothes
and then later building shelters and
then
you know etc that's one part of how we
were able to get tools in the first
place which is one thing about humans
that makes it sound absolutely
terrifying
is because we sweat we can run for a
really really really long time or would
have been able to it's not like humans
are doing this super frequently now
but would have been able to run for ages
without overheating and dying which a
lot of animals do so in theory
you could stalk a deer to the extent
that the deer would keep running and
would eventually overheat and die but
the human will be able to run for an
incredibly long amount of time because
we sweat and cool ourselves down and
that is how we were able to get the
tools in the first place
which is like really scary to think
about it's because we sweat
we get all gross and wet why is that
scary ages it's just thinking about a
human
chasing you for three days and being
like guess i'll just die because i'm too
hot now
how is that any different than cheetahs
developing the ability to
outflank their through sheer speed like
cheetahs can't maintain that speed for
more than a few seconds but just just so
few things that can go faster than that
other animals perspirate we're not the
only ones that do
uh other animals do at the time
i'm sure we've talked about animals
sweating on this show before
this is feeling very familiar no i'm
sure they do but it's just that the the
fact that we can
uh outrun things or in theory outlast
things is supposedly what lent us to
making tools
am i remembering this wrong troy i
remember this
i feel like i'm in a deja vu deja moment
come with me on this journey
there's like five animals and you listed
them last time
you knew them i know that um
there's there's something we will know
horses monkeys apes and hippos
yeah i know hippos someone please if
someone watching this remembers this
please do like a supercar because i feel
like we're in a full
repeat because i'm about to say that the
thing you said
is widely considered yes but i am i
think that's the thing
i said fire is the core because that
gets you communication and processing of
food so that you can uh so your brain
can film
that's probably i swear that's awesome
huh that's prometheus
i was gonna say that advancement this is
what i learned from
um the brilliant alice roberts i was
gonna say
i was just gonna bring her up because i
was like normally when you'd be texting
neil
to call in the cavalry on some design
verification which always goes my way by
the way
uh then yes i was like i bet he's
texting uh alice right now to say so i
got a quick
paleoanthropology question for you so
with this uh
wonderful uh i don't even know what
you'd call it it was such a weird hybrid
concert
play that that austin and i did with his
friend tony london
the three of the most brilliant minds on
the planet um
not including totally london and austin
wintry
um we were a net negative on the on
the curve down i don't know about you a
lot
across from um the lovely
world's one of the foremost leading um
uh what does she call herself it's it's
paleobiologists because
paleoanthropology anthropologist and and
also anatomist
i think would be a fair yeah she like
what she knows and and she's also a
surgeon
like she's just brilliant and an author
and she's just fascinating she's one of
those people like carl sagan that just
finds
wonder in what most people find
pedestrian
um and she can she did it as a side note
she did a tv special that i still
haven't
watched that every time i see the key
art for it go by in my twitter when
she's posting
or i think i need to watch that where it
was if we were designing humans from
scratch
how would we make them like because
we've obviously all
life is an inheritance of the lineage of
different forms we went through all the
way back to
single-celled you know pre-life
basically uh star stuff
yeah well yeah you want to go far enough
back yeah and so really
yeah so uh she she made a show on like
looking around at how other animals in
the universe
and the on earth rather uh how they have
adapted to various things and
if we could just kind of build this
chimera from the best of the world what
would it
what would her take be and and i i'll
never forget as i recall
the the um the like placental
kangaroo pouch thing she was like i
swear that that was if i remember
correctly that was part of it she was
like that's a better way
that's a better way to get your young
off the ground than what humans do
and like so the weird freaky kangaroo
human
was part of her like if we were
redesigning humans to be better
for a lot of all around you know
stronger better
that's one of the features they would
have and i just thought
i need to watch this show
yeah the the thing that yeah
alana you made a comment uh 22 years ago
um about it's an advancement evolution
is an
advancement and that's not entirely
accurate
um the the notion that because i always
thought evolution was the progression of
meaning it was it was the betterment of
which that's what we like we
are highly evolved we're an evolved
species that just simply means
it's a lateral move it's it's not up or
down
ev this conversation with alice roberts
that i had for for the thing that also
was talking about
was was a complete paradigm shift for me
because i
my arrogance allowed me to believe that
i am an evolved human
that you're the destination you are
though you are troy
specifically in the sense yeah i think
troy is i think at the end of that show
austin was talking about it just comes
up with an image
i think the i think the basically
basically
because i fly first class
i was gonna say the beginning of this
conversation that may or may not end up
getting cut
is
it doesn't make me any better but
there's at least context
but the the notion that it's not really
a a
leveling up as much as it is well the
world is you just happen to fit in
better to this
this is why evolutionary scientists hate
the classic ascent of man drawing that
shows like
you know chimpanzees and earlier apes
kind of gradually standing upright and
walking because that portrays it as
this sort of objectively superior
leveling up
and it's not how it is if we've spoken
about this before i would have said it
the last time but there's this thing in
pokemon where there's this old man who
goes
but if humans evolve from monkeys then
why do we still have monkeys
because the logic of all from monkeys
before legitimately to be clear we have
covered a lot
of doubt that we haven't the ascent of
man thing i'm sure i've heard before the
only person in the world
i would have heard that from it that
that was a legitimate argument that i
that i still must happen from the pulpit
yeah
guys it's ridiculous to think that we
have all for monkeys if we evolve from
monkeys then why are there still monkeys
dinosaurs yeah same thing why would
dinosaurs be great if
if they're not here anymore right
obviously they're bad
we won we're the best right but no one
even wants to
we all hand wave the notion that
two-thirds of this planet is water and
we could barely
like be in it for a second before we do
suck in water
yeah yeah no i think i think this
reminds me like the [ __ ] out just to
survive
that's the thing that i um we get all
pruning really
there for 20 minutes we can't even get
into it after we eat
i'm assuming it was massively disproven
but there was that theory in the 80s
wasn't there
the that we were in water for a period
of our revolution
well definitely well i would think that
there was yeah it seems
like someone at some point no there was
a there was there was a theory because
our hair grows
um in a in a streamlined water way
like basically all of our all of our
hairs are still slightly wetter
there's there was like i remember in the
80s i'm sure it's been massively
discredited now but there was i think it
was desmond morris like
had the the idea of the aquatic ape the
defining move of humanity was not to
stand up it was to swim
we still are in water we still grow in
water still need a lot of it seventy
percent
no yeah but i'm just saying a lot of bad
facts thrown out here i'm sorry
yeah a lot of this nice anyone watching
this definitely fact
check everything just to be clear here's
a fact
nine months we spend in water in liquid
breathing liquid for nine months yeah
did you know did you know that the thing
in the abyss with the breathing liquid
that's actually
a thing it's true yes your body will
remember i know i did
i love that [ __ ] scene it freaks me
out that first of all the two things
that i have in like 10 minutes but you
can do it for longer than you think
yeah the two the two things that i'm
terrified of mice
and drowning and that scene put them
both in one i was like
[ __ ] a drowning mouse i thought it
was going to be i thought it was going
to be drowning in economy class
[Laughter]
the ultimate humidifier oh this is uh
the part where i feel like it is
ethically responsible for me to
um intro the show hi everyone welcome to
play watch listen i'm alana i am not a
scientist
i write video games that's troy baker he
is also not a scientist he i am a
video games and i absolutely am a
scientist
100 of the scientists okay
so is austin so is mike fundamentally
disagree that is a video game director
let me
it is not something that i am uh
educated in uh
to the extent that i feel like you
should take my word on this show
thus i want to give the disclosure that
i am not a scientist and you should not
uh consider me a viable source of your
science news or facts
there's a difference though between
saying you should consider me a viable
source of science and i am not a
scientist
i would pray in it like this i would say
that you can be a science-minded person
you can live your life with a very
pro-science
and you but there's also just the idea
some of my best friends are scientists
troy what um what what what is it what
is your working definition of scientists
for them
i agree with there's so many people that
have stumbled upon
something in the process of wondering
and being curious
and i i the thing that the reason why i
pushed back against it so passionately
is because i hate this notion that you
must be a
um some form of academic you must
uh be accredited there must be a
certification there must be a profession
that is attached to whatever your
passion is and there have been
passionate people throughout history
that have truly advanced us by meaning
we have gained wisdom
gay knowledge gained art that have not
been accredited
the beatles couldn't read music i think
that that's something
someone taught them someone taught them
how to write george martin
said what if we actually did this to it
but they've all sat down
i've never had a piano lesson in my life
and i can't play
like a concert pianist would or someone
who went to juilliard
for piano but i could bang out some
chords and make a song
and so what i like to be clear troy like
you do
i agree with you that like you should be
very worried about any institutional
information you do
you do have the humility to have gained
some knowledge from existing
yeah you're building on the shoulders of
giants right which to me is the
scientific matter
so there are two definitions you need to
know stuff in order to build on that and
and if you don't know anything about
sciences none of us do you build as
you're gonna be a [ __ ] scientist
yeah so the reason that i give the
disclosure of not scientists is
is again because we are not
in any way expertly informed sources on
this matter
is any other thing professing that you
are are you professing that you are yes
i think
you have a responsibility uh if you have
a podcast that 90 000 people listen to
to be like
everything i said could be wrong oh no
okay
so you're saying that you have a you
have a responsibility
this is gonna be great so you're saying
that you have a responsibility
to people yeah i think it's simpler than
that i think it's
it's the distinction of if you're saying
i
am a scientist because it you mean you
are curious
about the world you are open to learning
you have a broad
fascination with how things work that's
very different than someone who says i
work in a particle collider all day
and i am running experiments that my
career is predicated on
absolutely i think it's about one word
implies you might be conceiving of
yourself as being like that other person
in the same way that like i love
encouraging amateur musicians but if
if someone consider the piano and poke a
few keys that they've never heard before
i would have no problem calling them a
composer but there is also a functional
difference from them
saying i'm a composer with no qualifying
remarks or anything from me saying it
right surely there must be
i would say that if someone goes the
perfect example
there was someone who recently took
credit for work that i did
i apologized doesn't matter that was me
in that game
i thought i did really well in the
medium and
we've all done that apparently that's my
performance as joel the last of us too
is and and the best it's you're like
that episode
of uh of family guy where um it's fred
savage is the best actor because he's
been rush limbaugh and everybody else
yeah yeah i made it relevant
i knew it i got the reference i had this
i had this immediately jerk that
reaction go
uh excuse me no you didn't and call him
out on his [ __ ]
and i really sat there for a while and i
i drafted the tweet in my mind of what i
would say to this person
but ultimately it doesn't matter i know
the truth
i know what i am i know that i did the
work he can say whatever he wants and
more importantly the second that i give
any credence or
or attention to that tweet
ign picks it up kotaka picks it up
variety picks it up it becomes a thing
so there's also a self-fulfilling
prophecy aspect of if that person is
saying that in order to try to get work
whoever
takes the bait will quickly discover
whether they have
any veracity or not well that'll be true
that is the difference when he
when this person was actively saying
i i want you to see this as my demo reel
and i want you to be able to hire me
because of this
that takes a different thing the
intention and the agenda behind it is
what makes it nefarious
that's what's brazen like that's amazing
that's very crazy has your work
in the reel is there any
is there any potential chance that like
now that guy did like some box or
something
for your character absolutely did he
absolutely so he's but he's using clips
of you your performance
he's saying that was me i did that and
there there have been people who
have workshopped and then it happens all
the time
to where um there are studios and this
is something that the union really
pushed hard against
because they're like no no no there's
any acting it must be done by actors
and most studios have some form
like aaa studios especially who who are
going to incorporate performance capture
into their pipeline
will have some volume set up in their
studio so that they can block scenes out
so that before they get
actors onto the stage where it's costing
tens of thousands of dollars to be there
every day
they go we've already moved this we've
already kind of worked it out it's
terrible we're shitty we use people from
accounting or whatever to make
this work to see if it'll work and
there's a lot of times like uh billy
harper did a lot of the
move sets for delson on a trampoline
because he's incredibly adept he's the
animation director
he knew exactly what he needed i
couldn't do it and he could
he was the best person for that job uh
hellblade um the fact that uh i'm
drawing a blank on her name right now
she was wasn't she the animation
director
i think in animation
she suited up and she won best
performance she crushed it it's the best
person for the job
there's a difference between someone
going i helped along this thing and
here's the person that actually did
that scene did that roll especially when
i'm in the credits it's that that that's
my role
but what i'm talking about is if someone
said if i go outside and i go
i'm going to perform a science
experiment today and especially
looking at traveler i want him to have
that curiosity that wonder
and not think that that curiosity and
that wonder belongs to
some other group of people it belongs to
him now and i was like let's do a
science experiment
let's find out what happens when we do
this if
then let's just do very very simple
cause and effect
that's a simple basic and i can look at
him and go see dude
you're a scientist today we just got
back from the park
and he was kicking a soccer ball a
football and i'm doing my best to
make to make sure that we call him i
even saw somebody else who's like we got
a proper footballer here
and he got it past feels like you gotta
pass the keeper let's get on the pitch
like i'm trying to
like understand that it's only in this
country now australia says soccer as
well
huh that's right all right so there's
two places he can go with that
but he's out there right now he's
kicking the hell out of that ball
and he's running and he's laughing i'm
not gonna look at him go you're not
actually a soccer player
you know that and you need to let people
know
we're kids so i would like to give you
the two
definitions of scientists the one please
prove me wrong you've been you've been
sitting on that real patiently you
deserve some credit
a person who is studying or has expert
knowledge of one or more of the natural
or physical sciences
two a scientist is someone who
systemically gathers and uses research
and evidence to make a hypothesis and
test them to gain and share
understanding and knowledge so the first
one is the academic
uh is the i'm not a scientist unless i
have expert knowledge which
you know is what i would align with but
the second one is a little bit more
inclusive in that it is saying that you
can be a scientist as long as you
systemically gather and use research and
evidence to make
sense surely that says systematically
yes sorry it does say systematically
correct yes
uh i definitely butchered that one but i
think that that one picture doesn't turn
a picture it doesn't require you to be
an expert it just requires you to
routinely
research uh well that would be the art
test
you can be a bad scientist that would be
that would be the argument
that would fit with what you're saying
is essentially yeah with all
love and respect troy to you and
traveller like traveler
yes a scientist probably that's a very
good one right like probably or at the
start of his scientific
i don't think cern is going to come to
them and go can you please help us break
this
yeah exactly they're not going to fix
this i don't think that anyone is going
to come to us and go
please help us um come up with the the
scientific answer for this dilemma
well see that's not even so you're
probably going to believe that they're
like an amateur scientist right but then
it's not a problem why well that that's
easier for me to address and be like i
do not have the expertise to do this but
for us to have a podcast where the four
of us do not work in the field and to
confidently say things about like
i read this and not make the disclosure
seems irresponsible
what what what confident thing did we
say
he said a lot of [ __ ] i said a bunch of
[ __ ] besides besides the moon is flat
which we know is true
i don't even remember what i said that's
why it's important for me to be like
don't listen to me
i just really annoying quality where
everyone thinks i know what i'm talking
about at all times
so many times in life it's just the
accent yeah
my concern we always believe that you're
true my concern is that we just
we kind of preemptively make assumptions
for people
as opposed to just being honest and and
saying
first of all i'm not i'm not a
professional driver i don't i don't
claim to be a professional driver so
before anyone gets mad at me for being a
professional driver i was on the 405.
it's like well hold on a second if you
were telling people like how the brakes
on their car worked
you you should probably provide the
information that you're not a great
driver that you're not a professional
driver
unless i happen to know empirically true
how brakes work on a car
this is where this is where we're making
something binary which actually exists
on a spectrum
yeah because yeah for sure i don't want
to say i am not a scientist it's like
well
yes i'm going to say i am not a
scientist i'm a science enthusiast
but yeah i tend to be i tend to be
closer to alana on this one i'm not an
actor i'm a performer oh [ __ ] [ __ ] off
i think i think i think for me
the the distinction is not about the
gatekeeping because i definitely agree
that that's
not productive that you know if somebody
if you say to somebody pick up a
paintbrush and
go have at it on this canvas and they're
like
well you know i'm not really i'm not a
painter i'm not it's like there should
be
that voice is only a negative presence
in your life so i agree
the spirit of what you're saying troy is
about barriers to entry
in like exploring life and the fullest
life so that we can have
fully with you but i think alana
ultimately does
draw a correct distinction that just
i am a scientist moving on is
slightly deceptive and so
the i said it's cautious what a really
good interview with a nasa scientist
about they were taught they were in
being interviewed about flat earthers
and like the the interviewer was they
must be so sick of that by now
well that was interesting so there was a
series of interviews it was in a there's
a documentary
netflix documentary was really
interesting about like flat earth uh
kind of enthusiasm and obviously that's
now blended off on you know
well i guess fortunately like there's
less of that but the reason there's less
of that is because they've all moved
over onto the q and on bollocks
um so unfortunately there's a weird kind
of transition point there
but the thing that was interesting with
the with nasa interviews is yes 90
of the interviews it was nasa scientists
going they're morons they're idiots this
is so annoying but there was one i
remember it thinking it was beautiful
kind of
sign of empathy and and the kind of
person i think
troy would would would agree with which
was basically a nasa scientist saying
these people are inquisitive they're
interested
they've been poorly educated and there's
a it's a shame that they're coming to
the wrong conclusions
but it does come from a position of
wanting to know answers or be interested
we need to catch these people and turn
them into good scientists that was
something that was expressed by that
i i think that's a very generous read of
flat earthers but i kind of i like i
liked it
very kind and gracious yeah and i think
the part of that that really resonates
with me
and i love that is that part of what i
think drives people towards flat earther
thinking or other q anon sort of
conspiracy theories and things like that
um are the fact that the experts
present it as this is a fact and if
you're wrong you're an idiot when in
reality
properly assessed they if you were to go
to
follow those experts to their
conferences it's a lot of
wrangling with truth do we know that
this is actually the case that
and so when they are seen as this
monolithic
impenetrable fortress where if you're on
the outside then you're an idiot
and it's this impermeable sort of wall
that it is seen as like well i'm not
getting through that i may as well find
shelter
elsewhere and if they if but science
isn't like that in practice in reality
and if so if they had
they come across as very arrogant in
other words as if you know
we are right you are wrong get over it
as opposed to like
the truest the truest way to say it
would be this is what we think is
currently true and there's a
mountain of evidence to support it but
we actually could be wrong like let's
show you why we think
it's right that's very different
attitude even if
that's great if the other party comes in
with good faith that's what i was going
to say
is i feel the opposite so i i actually
the to to mike's point of like speaking
about flat out authors and being asked
what you think of them i do think it
would be
a much more productive thing to do to
say well then explore that like
you know research it um that you can a
lot of discoveries occur when we're
trying to
research something else like you could
you could discover something that we
don't know definitely research it rather
than just call people idiots
but that community and of course you can
you know i'm generalizing
um is extremely arrogant and hostile
so to say well because they are isolated
that's the thing
you sound like a bit of a globe head
there alone
oh no we lost it honestly
yeah i'm trying to trying to see what
book is about to appear jesus
he's gonna find
[Laughter]
i see it the same way that i i regard
like
if you look at the the tiny subset of
the highly religious that
we could call the kind of really
fundamentalist like aggressively hostily
you know whether it's the the westboro
baptist or an islamist or any number of
other types that are just militantly
sealed off in their belief system and
not representative of the majority
umbrella within their belief system
i don't look at those people as
as sort of de facto evil i see them as
victims of indoctrination in almost
every case
where where they even those that become
the leaders
can be traced back to a moment where
they were at some crossroad
and they were either taken advantage of
or you know sold some snake oil
and ran with it now that's not to excuse
them or to say that those that are then
running a parish built on bigotry and
you know misogyny or homophobia or
racism or whatever and they're and
they're they
clearly should know better by this point
i think it's
i just think it's complicated and and i
will always
start from a position of trying to
empathize and think how did this person
get to be that person
because there were a succession of steps
where you know
as troya said at some point they were
just a baby and like
there was nothing about this which was
preordained and so
if we try to think back to there came a
moment or series of moments where
they were put on a path less than they
actively consciously chose a path and i
know that i can't speak for
everyone in this way there probably are
plenty of examples that would say they
had everything going for them and then
they just for whatever reason
chose a shitty path for their life like
i'm not denying the
possibility of that but i don't think
most crappy people
that is descriptive of and so when i see
a flat earther
in most cases i see them and i don't
mean this in a condescending way i mean
this in an empathetic way i see them
more as victims than as idiots
i definitely and i've i've been
uh we were um trying to think of
i think it was like in like serbia or
something it was it was really random
but there was there were flat earthers
that were out um and like
not protesting but kind of like changed
my mind kind of thing they were set up
uh on this on this bridge and i just
kind of sat and watched and i was like i
want to know
what this is and not i was familiar with
the theory but it's it's
what what causes this and then i watched
that documentary you know uh
behind the curve or whatever it's called
believing in the cube that's the one i
was talking about that's the one that
had that quote i said yeah
that's the one i'm just the hypothesis
yes of the hypothesis of a flat earth
and what i realized hypothesis
at the at the end of it i realized it
was like oh gosh i get it
i get why these people feel this way and
i think we've talked about this before
there are people that the system that
they were given
um has failed them because the system
that they were given failed their
parents that failed their parents and
was just it
speaking of evolution it's not that it's
getting better necessarily it's just
adapting to
the time to the child and i know this
because i'm
very aware of the systems that i was
given and the systems that i can tacitly
hand on to traveler even if i'm not
intentionally doing it i'm like
oh man i'm even just passively by the
act of doing this i am teaching him
and instilling a system in him that i
know will fail him
eventually and whether it's a teenager
or an adult it will fail him it will
break down
but watching these people there that the
system has failed them
and by and large these people are would
consider themselves to be
fundamental christians or having some
faith based
community that they're involved in or
faith-based system and
specifically with with uh fundamentalist
christians there is a notion i know this
from growing up in it
if you're being attacked
good you're right because we are not of
this world
i mean it's doctrinally in this world
it's doctrinally enshrined
in in in the bible that if you are being
persecuted
you are essentially righteous
like it it is it is it is a product of
your righteousness
the world will persecute you the world
will come against thing to indoctrinate
people your fields into isn't it when
people come against them and go
you're so stupid
that's just an end to the conversation
but the problem is
is the breaking down of when they do
these tests
there is they're they're so far bought
in
that it has to be something other than
truth hitting them in the face
it's because it becomes interwoven with
identity and what is
as soon as you're pulling at the threads
of what makes someone who they are and
not just that
but you know their community their
family
like their whole infrastructure of their
life this is again why i empathize
because i
i see the opposite end like there's a um
there's a um
youtube it's kind of in a way not
dissimilar from this except it's always
done live and it but it's on the subject
of religion where they have
people call in we're always talking
about video games they're always on
topic on on video games
yeah there's a on this uh show they
they're basically like a
a show for people that are calling in
anonymously
to say i am questioning my faith but i
live in a
really religious community and i don't
know who to turn to and i don't know
what to do
and they're panicking and these people
are it's all hosted by people that have
been there
and most cases lost their families like
been completely disowned or like in the
case of
you know like if you look at jehovah's
witnesses though there's this practice
of shunning which is
you know for the for the very ardently
believing not all jehovah's witnesses
are like this but it's pretty well
baked into the the design of that
particular sect
i was about 10 my best friend was a
jehovah's witness and because i wouldn't
go to church with her
i wasn't allowed to see her anymore that
was probably her parents
situation with a friend and that's what
i mean these people call in where they
grew up with that and then at some point
usually they found some video on youtube
that
raised some questions and they were like
wait maybe everything is
not true that i've been led to believe
but then they freak out because they're
like if i reject this belief
my whole world will explode and i don't
know if i can even survive it there's
even a thing called the
um crap i think it's called the the it's
called like the
preacher project or something like i'm
blanking on what it's actually called
but
there are actually a number of ministers
and preachers and pastors
that have lost their faith and feel that
feel completely trapped in their life
because they have no other marketable
skill
and they're like i've spent 40 years
some 40 year old game designers who
are in the same boat yeah well this
would be like imagine imagine you're
60 and you've spent you went to seminary
and you've spent the last 35
40 years at that point right yeah yeah
it's it's literally like i can't pay the
bills any other way than this
never mind that i'm i'm basically lying
to my
congregation so there there's like a
whole super anonymized very
very like you have to be vetted to be
led into this thing because it's very
important that
everybody's identity be protected
because they're they're in many cases a
central pillar of a community and
they're just trying to figure out what's
the right move for me here it's exactly
the same as like
if you played xbox your whole life but
then you really like ghost sushima it's
the exact same
it's a real struggle for these people
and admitting they don't know what to do
she's objectively better than the xbox
stuff like that how are they supposed to
do that it's their whole life
yeah just remember that they're victims
i just felt we needed more comments just
to kind of mix things up
hold on i
we've not touched on any controversial
subjects in this episode they just feel
like
they're calling it not quite very empty
so the identity stuff
of joel and elliot is that we got
comments being like i really uh can't
wait to hear you guys talk about the
casting
next week my name when i first started
off i was like just letting you know i'm
not picking this guy up but i heart
painter
i haven't even talked about it if that's
not the most on brand thing
look i this is what i truly i tr and
austin will back me up on this i truly
crave this
i love the organic discourse that just
pops up
out of like well wait a minute you said
that i want to understand more about you
so that maybe i can understand more
about me um that is what i'm all about
and if anyone ever thinks that this is a
disagreement
that is like a negative thing it is not
man these are i
there are very few people in the world
that i respect more than the people that
i have the fortune of
being in a square with every week um
and that's why i listen and that's why i
feel comfortable
asking and saying these things because
if if i felt like
first of all if i didn't respect you we
wouldn't have these conversations
number two i also want to learn
i want to i want to have my
my perspective in my if this last year
taught me anything
i have to change my world view my
worldview has to be bigger than what it
was
it has to be bigger than when i was 15
18
30 40 it has to be bigger than that
because i'm responsible now
for for a very very short time for the
custodianship of
someone who's going to go out in the
world and potentially do a lot of good
and i want to make sure that i didn't
instill in him a broken down system
that really failed me and that i give
him something that i better and
a lot of times it comes from
conversations like this it sure should
have come from conversations with austin
where i've learned more about myself and
how to be a better human
through these conversations and i if if
there's any kind of
behavior that i want to demonstrate from
this whether it be about video games tv
film books flat earthism or whatever
it's that
this is what needs to happen in the
world is we need to have more
conversations where we listen to each
other
and are truly feel comfortable sharing
our beliefs how do you feel about that
what do you think pedro pascal would
think about that
both of you just dug in man i got i got
instantly lit up there's there's this
picture the problem is what happened
troy was you spoke sincerely to an
australian
we have to make fun of it all we're
uncomfortable just like i'm sitting here
ready for the [ __ ] hug
[Music]
even if we do have disagreements i'm a
big fan of them that's that's how the
point is like
well and also going into a conversation
anticipating that you have an incomplete
sort of perspective therefore i'm not
gonna preach
i'm like bringing i'm putting it's like
a potluck like i'm gonna bring to the
table what i can
put it on now you put your part on now
you put your part on
and everything gets all mixed around and
you actually absorb that's the
difference when you just want to
proselytize and [ __ ]
get up on the thing like all right guys
listen real quick when i finish
i'm going to bounce because i'm not
actually here for anything other than
that you know like that's fundamentally
i think that's
that's fear that's insecurity that
drives that it's like
prove me wrong yeah
try to learn and hear things that i've
not heard before just in general at all
times always the same
can i give you a piece of trivia then
that i think is really cool that relates
to everything
about pedro pascal or jerry goldsmith
it's neither i'm sorry i'm sorry to say
jesus because i wrote this i wrote i i
came across an article that i meant to
bring up it's like i have my kind of
mental list of
play watch lists and subjects uh i do
that too
but we never get to any of them exactly
because i abandoned my list
you two used to like private message us
like with all of this we should talk
about this we should that's stopped now
that's just you you've ceased it i know
but this is not about porn and pores
that's true yeah alana talked about that
uh just to put that like i i didn't say
he was gonna be
i didn't say it was gonna be i i was
protecting the anonymity and the
sanctity of that threat
fair enough fair enough austin go what's
your ridiculous tribute so
when you when you were it's just perfect
because it's so amazingly on topic even
though this is something that i read
this by chance
i don't know months ago where um
when you were saying what the definition
of evolution is and it's not a it's not
the
it's not a ladder it's not a progression
forward the actual definition in
biological terms would be
variation in allele frequency over time
which basically is
another way to phrase it is population
mechanics which is what mike was talking
about
it's not that the whole population
suddenly becomes a new thing
it's that certain traits start to emerge
and then
those that flourish under that condition
will start to kind of outbreak
testing thomas was alone on switch
perfect example yeah
those that do will will have more
children they're successful
can you wish list on switch i don't know
if
so in one of the ways that
led darwin to discover uh
evolution itself was on the galapagos
islands
uh that as you go around the
circumference of the island the
different
species of finches the birds would
have the ability to interbreed with
their neighboring population
but as you kind of make your way around
the perimeter of the island those
across from one another can't that
concept is referred to as a ring species
where
because as species as uh populations
within a given species become isolated
given enough time they often lose the
ability to interbreed
because they evolve in different
directions from one another
and i've been some towns in england like
that except
i just wondered how you got them to like
do you just take two birds and go
do it do it yeah exactly
victorian era science was a little
messier than today in many regards
but yeah so point point being that like
it's a known phenomenon
that that you can have species that sort
of on a clock like in the
you know seven and two o'clock position
wouldn't be able to interbreed but the
one and two position would be because
they're just genetically similar enough
still even though they are distinct
populations and so one of the things
that one of the
ways that humanity has really come to
understand the mechanics of
where those dividing lines are because
we tend to think okay you know there's a
fundamental difference between
you know a lion and a tiger but the
reality is that as things diverge
those defining lines in closely related
species are
really hard and the whole idea of
cladistics and
drawing these uh these these uh these
trees you know the
kingdom phyllo et cetera et cetera et
cetera it's actually a very challenging
subject because
life is more complicated than that we
try to put it in these boxes to
make it understandable for our textbooks
but the reality is that life is just
generation after generation doing what
it's going to do and we're trying to
come up with rule sets to understand it
point being um one of the ways that
we've come to really understand how the
mechanics of this work is
from lice which i this blew my mind when
i discovered this
just i came across this on some article
by by accident
i wish um my baby
so because human there are there are
species of lice that can only really
live like on gorillas for example
and they will flourish all over the body
scratching oh wow that's true jesus
that's an amazing reaction
is that like the sympathetic yawn
feeling
um
they they uh they will be able to
flourish everywhere
on the gorilla's body because it's on
all interconnected system but what's
interesting
is that because humans we've gradually
lost
most of our hair relative to our
ancestors
most of us the more evolved ones among
us uh
we uh prove it because of that there
there is actually
there is actually a difference uh that
head lice and like chest
and body lice and forgive me
they are it is exactly the same as as as
species being separated by an island or
a mountain no
body lice amazing there there are
different forms of life there
are lucky stars the literals the literal
loss of hair created
ecological isolation and they cannot
interbreed anymore
wow and that blew my mind like it's we
are our own microcosm of how evolution
works
even within one body i found that to be
the
just because we we lost our hair on our
neck or we lost hair on wherever like
yeah the hair is varied that's super
interesting isn't that interesting
like they discovered they discovered a
lot about the underlying mechanisms of
evolution by studying lice and realizing
that
our lice are different than other ape
lice
and we have more species that can make a
home on our bodies than
than our counterparts in the in the ape
world i just thought that was the
coolest little
case study of how evolution works and uh
and the friends
i wanted to share that for like six
months and i'm gonna i'm done
finally the episode arrived we're gonna
call this the last episode um i have a
friend who's a chiropractor who's
actually been trying to convince me to
go for a while because supposedly there
are things in
chiropractic that can help with asthma
which i was not aware of
okay look i don't know there's there's
people that would go
for and against chiropractic medicine
i'm using the one where it's not quite
as scientific as the other one
there's there's chiropractor and there's
the other one it's the same thing as
acupuncture in that sense
like this and in the same office that i
went to i haven't gone there in a while
obviously but uh
there's an acupuncturist and there's a
um
a chiropractor and there's stuff where
he's like look man
you're you're look i'll show you your
right foot
is longer than your left and that's not
just because your tibia
is you know longer it's because your
hips are out because the way that you
sit he goes do you have a wallet in your
back wall i was like yeah he goes get
rid of that thing he's like
you're sitting in an unnatural way if
you do it for that long
it your your muscles will start adapting
to it and it throws your posture off if
your posture is off
i know this from running like it all
starts with your feet so
there's whether or not it can affect
those things i've heard it can affect
asthma digestive systems all sorts of
stuff
but it makes it here i think in the uk
it's classed as an alternative medicine
it's considered basically an alternative
medicine even though chiropractor
a chiropractor can't say i think in the
uk you're suffering yeah
a chiropractor cannot um uh give a
prescription but a doctor can
so there are people who are a doctor
that are also a chiropractor
but like my acupuncturist like look he
was like you called them
you know we um like meridians and stuff
that they've flown it's like
we we had terms for this before there
was a scientific definition for it
it's like if you touch this you will
feel better here and it's like i've sat
down and he's put pins at my back and
it's like
that pain is now gone or so do you
consider like something like acupuncture
is that a faith thing for you is that
like a almost like a
religious or spiritual thing no i think
that that you consider that science
i i would consider it somehow separated
from that
yeah i i wouldn't consider it a
spiritual practice at all in the same
sense that yoga is not a spiritual
practice
i think it is for some people is
probably the distinction there
what's interesting like reading that
that notion specifically came from this
alan watts book when he was talking
about the buddhist
practice of it it was like yoga is not a
spiritual practice neither meditation is
not a spiritual practice
neither is it it is something that we
we do but it's it's not a spiritual
thing this is this is about
well both have been secularized now
right like i i do meditation
and yoga like that's but you can do that
without any of the spiritual accents
yeah you can truly treat that as a
secular
yeah and tracking that trend actually it
was secular
then it was really really yeah then it
became a spiritual thing
and then it became this so yeah oh
that's interesting huh
um at least according to what i've read
um
but the i wouldn't say there's a
difference man you go into faith healing
all you want
whether there is something that happens
to your but we can get
lost in that whole thing but i i'm from
going to an acupuncturist and there's
several friends that i have and
anecdotal evidence suggests that there
is a difference there's there's a
physical difference
from going having a visit with uh an
acupuncturist
or a chiropractor versus not so take
that forward what i was gonna say about
the chiropractor was that they've
noticed a trend of
you know because they're people who deal
with with bones of
people's posture changing in a rounded
shape because people are now looking
down
so often because of their phones that
just in general
the stress in people's necks and the way
that they just stand normally
is is getting rounder earlier than it
would normally
and there was a discussion about whether
that would potentially become an
evolutionary thing whether there will be
something
that you know we won't know for a very
long time if because everyone is always
looking at this piece of technology that
is always down
if there will be some kind of change to
the way that we actually form or to how
our spines grow or something like that
because everyone is kind of depending on
that and it can give you neck strain
right now
whereas maybe eventually this is where
the challenge becomes that
gene because evolution is so much about
inherited traits genetically
it's hard for me to see how
that would be a thing because if someone
if someone had like a super liquid
skeleton and did not have any adverse
effects and constantly bending down
it's not like we live in a world where
that person is likely to reproduce at a
greater rate and therefore
spread their very iphone friendly
skeleton genes
that's true but isn't it still just
about people adapting
like their bodies physically adapting in
any case like well that's that's the
question of whether that's something
that's happened over a lifetime or is
genetically
presupposed the one that's interesting
to me is the human core body temperature
i just googled it sorry to make sure i
was right
human core body temperature has gone
down over the last
century by a tiny amount but we are now
we run colder than we used to
interesting the theory is that that's
because we live in
houses interesting
as opposed to being
yeah yeah just the humans basically
we've become softer basically we don't
we don't need to survive
outside as much as we used to so on
average of course there's variation from
individual to individual but
on average human body temperature has
gone down that's interesting
ramifications of that could be related
just want to give a shout out to
everyone in texas right now
it's a massive snowstorm and a lot of
the [ __ ]
lost power which seems absolutely awful
um presumably they're not set up for it
at all so like none of the
is infrastructures no power's gone out
completely um and then black ice is a
big thing so there are people just
sliding off of roads it's it's pretty
terrible so you know texas is a big
state anyone
if anyone's out there and you listen to
the show hope you're okay
please stay warm do not gas yourselves
people keep passing out
because of uh they're either having
trouble with their gas heating or with
their cars
to heat themselves up uh make sure you
you don't let your
your gases be inhaled get rid of them
somewhere
it's a huge bummer um hope everyone's
all right and i guess
their infrastructure is not designed for
that which is weird because i feel like
it snows there every year
but it's nice i think this is inordinate
this is like a blizzard and it's also
there's cold and then there's cold right
now yeah the european thing of like
there's cold which is fine
and then there's like the the freak
horrific stuff
doesn't it there's a great deal of
things that happen like in like 10
degree bar of
temperatures oh yeah for sure that are
disastrous especially with regard to
power lines and stuff or or windmills
that that uh
are generating electricity yeah no good
i have a friend who's i was his power is
out and but he was like
we're okay the kids went sledding that
was not a thing they were gonna
have in their in their childhood that's
true the classic texan hobby of sledding
yeah
so yeah a lot of very cute dog videos
people's dogs seeing snow that they
were never gonna see so that's that's
good
uh but generally just hope everyone's
all right um yeah and i guess on that
note
we should wrap up this episode of the
show that has nothing to do with we're
not gonna talk about
our video games do you wanna how do you
guys feel about lost what's costing my
opinion is that i feel like i wait for
performances and then don't
act as based on anything other than
their performances thank you good day
i don't know that i have anything to add
to that i think it looks i think it
looks like a fun
fun choice i think it fits fun choice
it's a it's a very fun guess yeah it's
the wrong word but i
think i think it's it's not it's not the
obvious choices for either character but
that's kind of interesting and i like i
like i feel like gestures towards it
being its own thing which i think no one
actually wants something that's an
absolute duplicate of the game
i think the game is the game i think the
show should be its own thing
people say they people like
the uncanny valley of translation to a
different medium
ruins it uh and the more that it doesn't
actively make us go oh that's this
that's this like i love the idea of
embracing
you know whole cloth differences uh and
but fundamentally to what you just said
alana i i was excited he's he's clearly
the real deal but i only know her from
the one performance but it was
the most memorable thing in the last
season of game of thrones
i [ __ ] own right yeah fair play yeah
i just i think
with it's weird because troy's in the
room but like i feel like
that's such a definitive performance of
that character in such a specific
actually john's sense of choices yeah i
don't want to see someone try and do
that
neither on screen particularly i wanna i
wanna let that be its own thing and
see the new thing troy what's your
opinion
i i found out uh you know a little while
before they were gonna announce and neil
i you know proven to him that i could be
trusted with you know sensitive
information so he's like hey something
you know this is
this is going to break and i was like
awesome because how do you feel i was
like i think it's an incredible choice
um because it does immediately on its
face
say we're doing something different and
that
the story exists beyond
the characters that performed it um or
the or even the the original telling of
that the story in the world
is bigger than just this game if it just
belongs on a disc that goes into a
to a console that's it's got to be
bigger than that come on
um so pedro pascal to meals like you
might as well
have presented the actor for joel with a
sack full of puppies and kittens because
he's bulletproof right now it's just
like
everybody loves a mandalorian he's
incredibly charming he's proven to be
incredibly versatile talented and
it's different without going look how
different we can be
and i think that if you had gone too far
down that road the casting of the actor
would have overshadowed the performance
so this to me is like we're different
threads the needle
yeah and i think it's incredibly and
he's been incredibly gracious um he
the way that he has approached the role
the way that he approached the
announcement the way that he handled it
shows that he's someone who genuinely
wants to be
uh he wants to service the role not have
the role service him
bella ramsay um same thing she was
she was incredible in that um in game of
thrones
i can't imagine how much she's grown
since that
was several years now so i'm curious to
see what that looks like
i think that she has a tougher road
ahead of her
um because i have no idea where they're
going to be taking
this story and i don't know you know how
far back they go and how far forward
they go
but um i definitely think that it's um
look
the to to kind of use the the same
um approach that we were talking about
before as far as scientists
i am not a casting director i i have
done casting before and i've done
directing before
um but the people that are in charge of
this franchise
are incredibly seasoned uh
informed um and proven
so i'm uh i feel pretty good about
letting them make this decision because
left to my own devices i probably would
not have made
as good of a call plus intuitively what
excites me above all
and this casting seems to demonstrate it
or be representative of that
is um the fact that neil
is a driving force behind it it's not
just
like the studio or whatever
yeah like he's and neil understands
the things that one needs to understand
just to put it maximally broadly but the
differences
between the mediums also what makes the
last of us the last of us
you know like clickers are not what make
the last of us the last of us or
like there's a lot of externalities that
even though that probably will be there
in some form or another you could get
rid of all that and not lose the essence
of what makes it what it is
and that's why i think this casting
represents that that is a well
understood thing that you don't need
a superficial duplication of whatever
traits it looks like from the outside
but then on top of that to have someone
like craig mason
who is also like a unbelievably
brilliant mind
in his own right and just fantasizing
about what
he'll do or is doing with this pla this
sandbox of like toys and
and saying like you know what if it's
this what if it's that and i feel like
i can obviously i don't know at all but
i can fantasize
that the two of them and whoever else is
at that table
are like cooking up ideas that then get
sort of
iterated on and end up driving it pretty
far afield but everything is done
through the normal rider
process that yields great [ __ ] and so
i'm like
i think this one may be the first one to
finally come along
that's like [ __ ] this anyone in the
world could watch this
and it doesn't you're you love it
you can springboard from a love of the
game into this and embrace it or you can
come in cold with no knowledge that
video games even exist
i i'm very optimistic that this has all
the right
hallmarks of finally breaking that curse
the biggest commonality that i think the
show and the game
will have is that it will do what the
game
what the last of us did for games i
believe that this show will do for
especially video game adaptations and
television i think that it will set a
new standard and prove
that you can do what you didn't think
you could do and do it with excellence
i sure hope so all right on that note
we'll see you on the next note that's a
better note that's the title of the
episode as well thanks to everyone who
watched the 15 minutes of us talking
about the last of us is what they were
here for i know i was gonna love it
topic starts at one hour 20 minutes
classic